SPARKY RHODE: Everybody, welcome
once again to the
"Android EMEA Developer
Relations Office Hours," where
we talk to you about anything
that's on your mind regarding
developing Android
applications.
I'm Sparky, coming to you from
a very cloudy and foggy
Munich, Germany.
Typical fall day here
in Central Europe.
And I'm also joined by--
oh, looks like Matt, Nick, Rich,
and-- who's that fourth
guy in London?
RICH HYNDMAN: Who's the
fourth guy in London?
WIEBE ELSINGA: My name is Wiebe,
and I'm one of the
organizers of the Dutch Android
User Group visiting
here in London.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, it's--
SPARKY RHODE: Awesome.
RICH HYNDMAN: The run-up to
Droidcon UK, the largest
Android-focused conference in
Europe, I guess, each year.
And it's kicking off tomorrow,
so Droids are appearing in
London from all over Europe.
So we're very pleased to be
joined by Wiebe here, and of
course his cohort, Johan,
has joined us
electronically as well.
And hey to Al Sutton for joining
us pretty much always.
[LAUGHTER]
AL SUTTON: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Good to have
you on board, Al.
I guess I'll see you tomorrow
in person at Droidcon?
AL SUTTON: Absolutely.
Yeah, I wouldn't miss
it for the world.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: How come you're
missing Droidcon, Johan?
JOHAN PELGRIM: Good question,
good question.
I think it's probably maybe--
RICH HYNDMAN: This is where you
slip in the bit about--
JOHAN PELGRIM: Oh,
the money thing--
RICH HYNDMAN: Droidcon
Holland?
JOHAN PELGRIM: Yeah.
That's true as well.
NICK BUTCHER: What is that
Droidcon Holland
of which you speak?
JOHAN PELGRIM: No,
that's one thing.
Of course, there many
conferences and I desperately
want to go to Google
I/O next year.
So I'm not to trying to control
my management with
Droidcon UK.
And as you say, Nick, we
have a Droidcon in the
Netherlands as well.
And Wiebe is there, so he
can report back to us.
So basically that's it.
WIEBE ELSINGA: I'm
on a mission.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
Well, I'm definitely really
looking forward to
Droidcon this year.
It will be the biggest, baddest
Android conference ever.
When I say bad--
NICK BUTCHER: In the Michael
Jackson sense.
[LAUGHTER]
AL SUTTON: Getting dodgier.
[LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, so
on to Android.
So before we kick off with the
Moderator questions, I'll make
the standard disclaimer that
we're not going to talk about
any roadmaps, future products,
anything that's unannounced.
And if anybody from the floor
inside the Hangout has a
question for us live, please go
ahead now, else we'll hit
the Moderator.
JOHAN PELGRIM: Well, basically
I was trying to find out what
the status is on the Gradle
builds, because we are a
preview, and how focused is
Google to get this into
production phase or where we
can actually use it in
production?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I think
it's classified as
experimental at the moment.
I think that's how they refer to
it in most of their posts.
So I don't know is the answer.
Like, Al, you probably have
followed this a lot closer
than I actually have.
Is the aim to finally get it
to production quality?
Or is it more of an experiment
to find out what we need or--
AL SUTTON: It's currently on the
experimental side, but the
idea is to replace the current
build system with something
that Jake Warden's happy with.
Or rather something that has
more features and can deal
with more situations.
So eventually it will become a
replacement for the current
build system, and there'll
be an overlap time.
But it's very early days yet, so
best thing is to jump on to
adt-dev, the Google group,
and follow it on there.
And contribute back if you think
it's not going in the
right direction.
NICK BUTCHER: Are we still
on preview 0.2?
AL SUTTON: I believe so, yes.
NICK BUTCHER: Very early days.
JOHAN PELGRIM: OK, thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Have you had
a play of it yet, Johan?
JOHAN PELGRIM: Yeah, just
a simple build.
Just have tried it once, so--
I haven't tried it for
production yet.
I'm using Maven, by the way.
So I'm not entirely happy
with that, so I'm--
NICK BUTCHER: Uh-huh.
JOHAN PELGRIM: Desperately
wanting to get my hands on
Gradle Build.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool All right.
So you've got some
new people who've
joined us in the Hangout?
Who have we got?
SPARKY RHODE: Tell me that's
not me echoing.
Doesn't look like it.
OK.
We've got a bunch of people
in the Hangout now.
MATT GAUNT: The live
stream just freezes
at this point here.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
Nick.
Al.
We've got [INAUDIBLE]
Al, Android developers,
Ernest, who is this?
Guiseppe, Johan we've got,
and Linda Knerling.
Hi.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi, BJ.
SPARKY RHODE: Welcome.
Glad to have you all
in the Hangout.
It's really great to see
such a big group here.
Does anybody else have a topic
of interest or concern that
you would like to bring up?
[BEEPING]
ERNEST: I don't know.
Can you guys hear me good?
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
ERNEST: All right.
So I actually had a question
just because I'm
a pretty new developer.
I haven't programmed or
anything, like I just started
in the past three months.
Anyway, long story short.
I came out with my first app
yesterday, and I'm not sure if
this is the right forum--
--to actually come on top
of search results?
SPARKY RHODE: My app is still
not the top search result for
its own name.
ERNEST: Yeah.
You see, that's--
I mean, I'm trying to just give
my friends the name of
the application and they
just can't find it.
So it kind of sucks.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
sometimes--
definitely near the start of an
application launch, it can
be best just to deep link
people straight with the
package name to your
application.
Also, if you search for the
package name, it will appear.
Obviously, when you're searching
for app titles, then
search rankings do apply.
So it's going to be all down
to numbers of installs,
ratings, and 198 other different
factors related to
how we rank listings
into Play Store.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Or maybe the
filtering the application--
RICH HYNDMAN: Mm-hmm.
WIEBE ELSINGA: If there is
a index specification--
index on the manifest.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
There is also the possibility
that your friends' devices
aren't supported by
your application,
so it may be filtering.
But often it's just the market
filtering out some of the apps
with fewer installs.
So getting some installs of your
app will definitely help
it appear in the search rankings
and appear further up
in the search rankings.
ERNEST: Gotcha.
NICK BUTCHER: And
your issue is--
ERNEST: All right.
That helps.
NICK BUTCHER: Sometimes--
what's your app called?
ERNEST: It's called Have To Do,
and it supports all the
way down to API level 4.
So--
RICH HYNDMAN: Nice.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, the one
issue we've heard of before as
well is if you have--
the name of your app is close
to a dictionary word but
slightly changed, like just
one word different to a
dictionary word, sometimes
our query rewrite-- you
know, Did You Mean--
could be a little bit
too aggressive.
So in those cases, you can
report that using the
developer console.
Or you can report developer
issue and we'll take a look at
that to make sure our search
algorithm's not being too
aggressive with its rewrites.
RICH HYNDMAN: Have To Do--
sorry.
NICK BUTCHER: But yeah,
yours doesn't sound
like a case of that.
RICH HYNDMAN: It doesn't sound
But Have To Do is quite a
generic set of three words
that could relate to many
different apps.
I mean, you could call it--
[INAUDIBLE]
to do list--
SPARKY RHODE: If the words are
separated by spaces, then put
quotes around the phrase,
and that will fix it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
I tried that.
It didn't come up.
SPARKY RHODE: Oh.
OK.
NICK BUTCHER: It's quite
a generic name, though.
There's a lot of apps
fighting for To Do.
ERNEST: Yeah, it's
just weird that--
exactly that.
Like the guy mentions, if quotes
around it would help.
But apparently not.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, package
name should usually do it.
You just need to get some
installs and hopefully it will
start appearing in
the rankings.
Consider--
personally, I would consider
changing the name as well.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Because it's never
going to be that easy to
search for that name unless it
becomes a really, really
consumer-orientated brand.
WIEBE ELSINGA: So
be more unique.
RICH HYNDMAN: Be more unique
on the name than calling it
something To Do.
OK?
NICK BUTCHER: And
congratulations on launching
your first app.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Awesome.
ERNEST: Thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: Anything else
from the Hangout?
AL SUTTON: I've got a carry-over
from last week,
where someone was asking about
TrustZone on processes and
using it for secure
processing.
RICH HYNDMAN: Uh-huh.
AL SUTTON: It tends to only
be used on bootloaders.
Basically what happens with
TrustZone is it sets up two
separate worlds on the core or
the multi-core device, where
the two cannot communicate
except through a very well
defined API.
And it assigns hardware
resources to work from to one
or the other world.
Android tends to run in what's
known as the normal world, and
things like secure bootloaders
and stuff tend to run in
secure worlds.
It tends not to be something
that will be useful from an
application in Android.
It's more designed at hardware
manufacturers to use.
So hopefully that answers
last week's question.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
Well, thanks for that
extra detail.
Any other live questions
in the room?
Who do we have?
Giuseppe, how are you?
Did you have a question
for us?
RICH HYNDMAN: We can't
hear you there.
You may be muted.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah, Giuseppe's
been muted.
RICH HYNDMAN: Was he
beeping earlier?
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, was that
the beeping noise?
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
If you have a message for us,
we still can't hear you,
Giuseppe, so maybe just type it
in the chat window, or find
out how to un-mute.
NICK BUTCHER: I think
there was a--
was there a question in the
sidebar as well before we
dropped out?
MATT GAUNT: From Linden, yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Has anyone
still got that?
Or is Linden--
AL SUTTON: Yep.
Linden says, is there a means
to determine if talking--
GIUSEPPE: Can you hear me now?
AL SUTTON: Partially talking--
SPARKY RHODE: Yes.
AL SUTTON: Or to queue an
accessibility announcement.
SPARKY RHODE: OK.
Let's go to Giuseppe and
then we'll get back
to the sidebar there.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
SPARKY RHODE: Hi,
Giuseppe, again.
GIUSEPPE: OK.
SPARKY RHODE: Thanks for--
GIUSEPPE: So you must
hear me now, right?
SEVERAL VOICES: Yes.
GIUSEPPE: Very good.
MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
GIUSEPPE: So I already--
hello--
already asked this question to
Richard in Italy, because I
had the good chance to meet
him here last week, right?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
GIUSEPPE: And we still confused
Richard of Frankly
Speaking about the action bar
problem, because we are still
getting from this Jake Wharton
information that he want to
leave this project.
So we are using this
ActionBarSherlock for old
version before own combo.
We are using this Sherlock bar
action bar for our application
but we don't know
what to do else.
Because the action bar compact
that Google team is
developing, it's stopped there
from long time now, and not
any update anymore.
And actually, we don't
know what to do.
That's it.
That's my question
at the moment.
NICK BUTCHER: So what's
the actual question?
RICH HYNDMAN: So the question
is, we don't have a compatible
action bar that does
what he wants.
And Jake Wharton is saying he's
going to stop working on
his own one.
NICK BUTCHER: Mm-hmm.
RICH HYNDMAN: What should
the developer do?
Should he use Jake's,
or should he--
NICK BUTCHER: When did
Jake say that?
RICH HYNDMAN: He posted
it on G+.
NICK BUTCHER: What,
their deprecated
from inception place?
RICH HYNDMAN: I don't know
what it's called.
GIUSEPPE: Sorry?
NICK BUTCHER: What did
Jake actually say?
He's not going to
carry on with--
GIUSEPPE: He said that during
the last I/O he was very good
received by the Google team,
but after this time, no any
more contacts, no any chance
to include, probably, the
ActionBarSherlock
inside the code.
And probably he will leave
the project and
will not update anymore.
This is on his blog right now.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
I haven't seen that place yet.
I can't comment,
again, on that.
But I guess the situation is
that ActionBarSherlock works
very well on all their
devices, so
I wouldn't be concerned.
In fact, I always recommend it
to developers for backwards
compatibility.
I think it's fine to use.
If he's not going to carry
on work on it, I
think that's fine.
So, say any new functionality
gets added to the action bar,
for example, in the future,
perhaps it won't be back
ported to all the devices.
But you're already at a certain
functionality level
now, which is good enough.
At Google I/O, we said we are
going to release our own
backward-compatible action bar
version, which we obviously
haven't carried out yet, we
haven't launched that yet, but
I believe it's still coming.
So there was another project--
so just say that I get
confused-- there was another
project called ActionBarCompat
which is in the SDK samples,
which was--
that's not the same thing.
That is an older, much, much
more simplified kind of-- it
looks like an action bar, but it
doesn't offer the same kind
of API surface, for example.
That's an older project which
has been deprecated in favor
of this newer one, which we
have announced but not
launched yet.
So I hope that's clear.
Yeah.
So I would say you shouldn't
have any fear using
ActionBarSherlock right now.
It's a really, really
awesome project.
And it's open source, so even if
Jake leaves it, then many,
many, many other contributors
may still pick up the reins,
yourself included.
Plus, there's also this
forthcoming project from
Google itself, which
if you choose to
wait, that's your decision.
But until then, there's
ActionBarSherlock.
GIUSEPPE: OK.
Very good question.
Very good answer.
Thank you very much.
NICK BUTCHER:
[SPEAKING ITALIAN].
GIUSEPPE: [SPEAKING ITALIAN].
SPARKY RHODE: I answered that
question in the Moderator in
three words.
I said, use what works.
NICK BUTCHER: "Use
what works." [LAUGHTER]
NICK BUTCHER: That's a
good summary there.
GIUSEPPE: Yes, that's right.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Shall we move on to the first
Moderator question, talking
about the Moderator?
Oh,no.
We said we'd look at Linden's
query-- sorry--
in the sidebar.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
We've also just had the first
Moderator question, because
that question was in
the Moderator.
RICH HYNDMAN: Two birds,
one stone, dead.
Right.
Can someone read what it
says in the chat bar?
It's distant.
SPARKY RHODE: Sure.
"Is there a means to determine
if a TalkBack is currently
talking or to queue an
accessibility announcement?"
It goes on to say--
GIUSEPPE: [INAUDIBLE]
Google.
SPARKY RHODE: Of an
accessibility
event, is what I meant.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
15 people are going to
speak to Giuseppe.
[LAUGHS].
SPARKY RHODE: I don't know.
I mean--
right.
Because these audio patches tend
to play asynchronously,
don't they?
So I don't actually know if we
have an API to say, no, it
hasn't finished yet.
Do you guys know?
RICH HYNDMAN: I don't know
either, with TalkBack.
I kind of assumed it was
pretty autonomous.
Tell it what to do and
it just gets on with
it in its own time.
Queueing up things and
talking about them.
But I haven't used it myself in
anything similar as to put
content descriptions
in my XML tags.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't have
anything else that I've found.
Yeah.
Perhaps if you could post that
question to Stack Overflow and
send us a link, might the best
way to tackle this question.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, we
can take that one
offline on Stack Overflow.
That would be quite cool.
He is currently doing a post
delay to interrupt and be the
last thing talking.
Yeah, fair enough.
Sorry, but we haven't too much
experience in that to
comment right now.
But, yeah, the Stack Overflow
idea would work well for us.
Put it on Stack Overflow and
we'll check it out on there
and see if we can answer
it offline.
MATT GAUNT: Sounds good.
RICH HYNDMAN: Cheers.
Next from the Moderator,
Sparky.
SPARKY RHODE: Sure.
Let's see what we've
got queued up.
NICK BUTCHER: This question's
in the G+ thread as well.
SPARKY RHODE: This is from
Reini in Austria.
"Would you mind explaining the
best way to animate changes to
the action bar such as
expanding, collapsing an
action view or replacing the
available menu items." I
responded by saying, I just call
the methods and let the
system do what it will.
But there is a very, very easy
way to get a simple animation,
to which is you just put this
into your style.xml.
You can put
android:animateLayoutChanges
true, and that property will
then actually animate the
insertion of a new item into
your action bar instead of
just having it pop into place.
So it's not like a great big
animation, but at least it
gradually slides all the
existing items over and puts
it in there.
NICK BUTCHER: I've
not tried that.
Is that similar to when you
invoke the contextual action
bar and it kind of does a nice
little rotate animation.
Is it similar to that?
SPARKY RHODE: It's
not a rotate.
It's just a little
slide into place.
NICK BUTCHER: That sounds cool.
Cool.
Didn't know that.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah, I mean--
NICK BUTCHER: So where do
you put animate changes?
Where do you state that?
SPARKY RHODE: So it's
interesting.
It's listed as a property
on view containers.
But I didn't see any way to
access the action bar as a
view container.
I didn't find any API
to hang that on.
So I put it into the top
level of style.xml.
So I said--
NICK BUTCHER: Oh.
So every layout change
will be animated.
SPARKY RHODE: Yes.
Exactly.
That's what I did.
So.
NICK BUTCHER: Mm.
Sounds a little bit too broad.
You should probably be able to
apply it just to the action
bar somehow.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah, I couldn't
find an API to specifically
hang it on the action bar.
Maybe there is one, but
I didn't see it.
NICK BUTCHER: Hmm.
[LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: Hmm.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
[LAUGHS].
SPARKY RHODE: Then I went
on to say there are some
callbacks that happen in
response to adding things to
the action bar.
And you could always catch those
callbacks and insert
your own animation
if you wanted to.
Draw animator rectangle of
zipples going from your button
to the action bar, and then push
everything over and grow
it into place.
Something like that.
You could probably patch into
those callbacks and put that
in yourself.
NICK BUTCHER: With your
action view, perhaps.
Because expanding class
in an action view.
So essentially you're writing
you own view, aren't you?
The action view is like
the search view is.
So I think once you're in that
territory, you can just use
the normal view property
animator methods.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
SPARKY RHODE: I see that
Giuseppe has given us a
question on the sidebar.
He says, "I would like to know
if, for the future, Google is
planning to do any own IDEs
specific for Android instead
of Eclipse?"
I've been in companies that
have gone down that road
before, and making your own IDE
is a huge amount of work
with relatively little marginal
additional benefit.
And that's why there exist
things like Eclipse, which
companies very commonly
will either fork--
which is also an approach
I don't recommend--
or write plug-ins for
as we do today.
NICK BUTCHER: Didn't we just get
behind joining the Eclipse
Foundation yesterday
or something?
AL SUTTON: Google became a
strategic member of the
Eclipse Foundation, which means
it's going to provide
the organization with eight
full-time developers to work
on Eclipse.
So hopefully work from the
inside rather than making a
copy and working from
the outside.
GIUSEPPE: Good.
WIEBE ELSINGA: More stability.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, that's
much better.
NICK BUTCHER: And I think
generally our approach with
the Android tooling as well is
to try to be as IDE-agnostic
as possible.
So while we try to provide
good support in Eclipse--
because that's the most
used IDE [INAUDIBLE]
that's out there--
but I think most of the tooling
is designed to have an
API surface that can be hooked
into other things.
So IntelliJ, for example,
is very popular.
IDE is able to take advantage
of all the many ADT
improvements quite quickly.
So, yeah.
I think we attack it from
both fronts, really.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
So I'm actually really glad to
think that we're not making
our own IDE.
I think that would
be a mistake.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
GIUSEPPE: Excellent.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh.
Al Sutton is typing.
[LAUGHS].
He just put a link to the--
AL SUTTON: Just a URL
for you guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: --Google
Eclipse detail.
GIUSEPPE: Thanks.
Thanks, Al.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
You said that we have
some questions
in the comment thread.
NICK BUTCHER: Mm.
A multitude of long questions.
RICH HYNDMAN: Multitude
of long questions
in the comment thread.
SPARKY RHODE: Oh, goodness.
NICK BUTCHER: Firstly, David
says, "nice shirts."
MATT GAUNT: Thanks.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Thanks.
RICH HYNDMAN: Cheers.
NICK BUTCHER: Thanks.
RICH HYNDMAN: Classically
attired.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: It's
a strong shirt.
And then also, it goes on to
ask-- he flatters first to get
our attention, and then asks,
"Do you think to include QR
technologies more in Android
systems?" To which I would
probably say, duh?
RICH HYNDMAN: But didn't the
original ZXing zebra crossing
library did come out
of Google, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Mm-hmm.
RICH HYNDMAN: So everybody has
the capability to have QR
technologies inside every single
Android device and
every Android app.
So, the only thing we could
go further would be
pre-installing that on
the apps, I guess--
on the devices.
But that doesn't sound
like something we
would go out and do.
NICK BUTCHER: I like it when
the OS doesn't try and do
everything as well.
It kind of leaves room for this
vibrant app kind of model
ecosystem out there.
But by standardizing
on certain intents,
they can all compete.
RICH HYNDMAN: It would be
maybe nice if the camera
recognized QR codes and said,
you don't have a QR code
scanner installed.
Would you like to choose one?
AL SUTTON: They could
make Goggles the
default camera app.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, Goggles
doesn't even come
pre-installed, does it?
AL SUTTON: No.
One of the things would be
putting it into the framework
would cause a problem for Google
TV which, of course,
doesn't have a camera
embedded in it.
So what would applications do?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
True.
RICH HYNDMAN: Just like
the camera app
that's in the framework.
[LAUGHS].
Yeah.
But, really, I think the answer
to that is you don't
really comment.
SPARKY RHODE: I think having
a QR reader is really nice.
QR as a method of sharing leaves
a little something to
be desired.
So for a sharing UX, I
think we're leaning
more towards NFC instead.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
High five that Beam.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT GAUNT: This goes for the
two people go into high five
and their phones just go pfff!
[LAUGHTER]
MATT GAUNT: Anyway.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
High five slow, and slow-motion
high five, and
speeding on the way through.
MATT GAUNT: Gentle--
RICH HYNDMAN: And then psssh.
NICK BUTCHER: You want
to read this--
one of the long questions?
RICH HYNDMAN: Read it off the
10-inch tablet because it's
such a question.
MATT GAUNT: So, Andre.
Question one of three.
"We are working on a product
that uses In-App
subscriptions.
When the app search service is
running, it uses some of our
server resources.
That costs us money."
And the problem is, "what can
we do if someone creates an
account, buys a subscription,
and then shares the account
between 20 people or worse
on some forum?
Can we only allow, say, five
simultaneous connections from
one account to be active
at the same time?
I know that if you buy something
in your account, it
should be accessible on
all of your devices.
I hope the suggested solution
doesn't break this rule.
Service accessible, but you have
to disable it first, or
somewhere else."
RICH HYNDMAN: Which sounds like
you're allowing people to
buy a subscription to a set of
logon details that aren't
related to their device, which
maybe isn't a great idea.
I mean, if you buy a
subscription, then you should
tie it to the account that
the subscription
was purchased from.
Because then you can check
if the person owns the
subscription, and if they're
logged in with that email
address on all their devices,
they get access to that
subscription from all
their devices.
NICK BUTCHER: So you're saying
if they share that account.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
Like [INAUDIBLE]
shell account just for buying
a subscription.
RICH HYNDMAN: That would break
the entire Play model.
I mean, you could buy every app
in one account then share
it with a thousand friends.
And actually, we would probably
shut it down, but--
if--
seems--
SPARKY RHODE: I have noticed
that some of the Google Play
properties do ref counting.
The other day, I was a
little bit surprised.
I was not expecting it.
I tried to listen to a music
track using Google Music, and
I got a little dialog box that
says, attention, you already
have 10 devices registered to
this Google Music account.
Please de-authorize one.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Anyone who tests a lot
of devices gets that.
I've been there as well.
It's not just because we all
have 10 devices each, but as--
this is a problem I faced
with Eurosports as well.
You subscribe to that and it
only allows five devices.
So as you migrate across
devices and you change
handsets and tablets, the
service provider needs to
provide an interface--
which we do for Google Music and
Eurosport as well, where
you can log into the internet
and then say, it no longer
works on this device, this
device or this device.
NICK BUTCHER: So that's why the
question is asking, can
they do that?
Can they have a maximum number
of devices from which it will
allow the subscription?
I don't know.
And does it break any
rules to do that?
I don't know of any rules
they're breaking--
RICH HYNDMAN: No, the Eurosport
app does it, and
I've never heard any
complaints to
tell me about it.
NICK BUTCHER: That's using
our subscription?
RICH HYNDMAN: And Music.
SPARKY RHODE: It does seem like
you ought to be able to
say,
RICH HYNDMAN: As long as it's
in the terms and conditions.
SPARKY RHODE: --no more than
five devices in one day,
perhaps, or something
like that.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's going to come
down to whether you start
getting bad user feedback and
lower ratings, in which case
you need to change your
system, really.
I mean, the users will revolt if
you implement it poorly, so
that they aren't constantly
having to authorize and view
authorized devices.
NICK BUTCHER: I think he's
happy with that.
I think he's mostly concerned,
is he breaking any of our
rules, because we are very keen
on subscriptions being
available on all a
user's devices.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: And the answer, I
don't think any of us know,
but I doubt it.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
Like you say, if you start
getting negative feedback,
then it sounds like you're
doing something wrong.
I don't think anyone would sit
there and complain, oh, I've
tried to download this onto my
20th device, and you're saying
I can't do it.
What's wrong?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Potentially,
I mean.
SPARKY RHODE: Seems like an
opportunity for an ask for the
Google Play infrastructure to
watch for signs of abusive
numbers of devices configured
to a single account or
something like that.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, I'm
sure it already does.
SPARKY RHODE: Maybe.
Cool.
NICK BUTCHER: Flags do fly.
MATT GAUNT: So, should I move
on to question two?
RICH HYNDMAN: Go on, man,
part two of three.
MATT GAUNT: Go on then.
Number two.
"Why doesn't the billing service
give us the account
that was used for the
In-App purchase?
It would be really useful when
there is more than one account
on the phone.
Now anyone on a Rigid phone can
just copy the DB, say that
you've bought the
subscription.
We can't verify if the account
that bought it is really on
the phone, because we don't
know which one it was.
When you encrypt the DB with
some device-unique key, it's
just a minor bump on
the way to create a
crack-up." So, yes.
Getting access to the
actual account.
It's an interesting one.
SPARKY RHODE: Doesn't the
Google Play merchant
transaction history
say what account?
RICH HYNDMAN: It does, but it's
awkward to get to, and
it's not on the device.
SPARKY RHODE: Mm.
RICH HYNDMAN: You get
the transaction ID
on the device, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Mm-hmm.
SPARKY RHODE: Hmm.
AL SUTTON: You could use it to
log into a damp app engine
application using the Account
Manager, which would register
that subscription as being
active, and that would give
you the details that come from
the Account Manager for the
Google account.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, there
is a bit of a
disjoint, isn't there?
Asking the users to choose
which account, or--
NICK BUTCHER: But how do you
know which account, if they
have multiple accounts
on the device, Al?
AL SUTTON: And that would
be the problem.
They'd have to select one.
But I'm guessing if they're
buying it, they'd pick which
one they want to associate
it with.
If you pop the dialog up saying,
which of the Google
accounts on the device do you
want to associate this
subscription with?
RICH HYNDMAN: Hmm.
NICK BUTCHER: I think
that would
probably be the best bet.
SPARKY RHODE: I would think
that you probably couldn't
associate the subscription with
any account other than
the one that bought it.
That bought the app, but--
MATT GAUNT: Can't you get a list
of purchased items from
the billing service for
the logged-in account?
Because isn't it in the sample
app, if you're doing--
RICH HYNDMAN: No.
Oh, you mean do a--
MATT GAUNT: Restore
transactions.
RICH HYNDMAN: Restore
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
And then you--
RICH HYNDMAN: So then you could
find out which is the--
MATT GAUNT: See, yeah, you--
RICH HYNDMAN: If the current
account logged in is the one
that bought the thing you could
find out from that.
MATT GAUNT: You'd have to
match transactions ID,
otherwise you'd just have
to then say, no, you--
RICH HYNDMAN: Also, restore
transactions works on the
account you bought it from,
not the one that's
currently logged in.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, there is
a bit of a disjoint.
I guess it would be nice to
have an API where you say,
this is transaction ID, this is
the account they logged in.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Does this match?
NICK BUTCHER: What if
the billing service
returned the account?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: If the billing
service returned the account,
it probably should be easier.
NICK BUTCHER: Good feedback.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, it's good
feedback from Audrey there--
Andre?
[INAUDIBLE].
All we can do is pass that
back to the billing team.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: And see
if they come back
with a better solution.
Hmm.
Yeah, go on.
Might as well go on
to part three,
even though we haven't--
MATT GAUNT: Thanks
for nothing.
"I haven't found out anywhere in
the docs what happens when
the account that was used for
buying the subscription is
removed from the phone.
Do you receive a cancelled
purchase broadcast sent by the
bank's service?" I wouldn't
have thought so.
SPARKY RHODE: No, I don't
think so, either.
MATT GAUNT: It would still
be part of the account.
RICH HYNDMAN: That person is
still subscribed to it, and
they can still log into the
Play Store and see their
subscriptions on the web.
MATT GAUNT: I don't think you
get a cancellation signal
unless they go into the Play
Store and hit Cancel.
RICH HYNDMAN: I don't think
it's cancelled, yeah.
That would suggest that if you
reset your device, it would
cancel all your subscriptions
until you then re-added the
account, and then re-added
them again.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
But I guess this kind of comes
down to what we talked about
in the first question, where if
you start sort of managing
the user devices that they've
logged in on, then this kind
of starts coming out for free.
Rather than cancelling it the
minute they disconnect that
account from a device, they
cancel it on whatever
mechanism you come up with.
RICH HYNDMAN: Also, you don't
get cancellation notifications
at the time.
You just get the--
at the end of the billing
cycle, you get the--
it's then cancelled.
Instead of re--
They did.
Sorry, there was a comment
thread that you liked?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
I think it's Chow?
Hi.
I am Chow.
I live in Phnom Penh,
Cambodia.
I want to join your
Hangouts now.
I love Android so much.
How can I join you?
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, that's nice.
I'll add you to the Hangout
Circles, Phnom Penh, and you
can come in.
I mean, we've got one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven-- yeah, we've got room.
I'll see if I can
add you as a--
SPARKY RHODE: While I was out of
the loop for a moment, did
you guys get to Giuseppe's
question
about reply to comments?
MALE VOICE: Nope.
Go for it, Sparky.
GIUSEPPE: Can I ask in person?
SPARKY RHODE: Please.
GIUSEPPE: OK.
Well, I have a couple of
question about the Play
Console, OK?
The first--
I think that the first is, it's
very famous, but we need
to at the whole find a way to
reply to people that give
their stupid--
sorry--
their comments to the
application using the video.
So we have to find the solution
as soon as possible,
because we need to reply them.
Otherwise, you make a lot of job
a lotter job, and because
the user don't know how to use
the application, or probably,
he don't know well the English,
then at the whole he
would put just that one stars,
and your application rate
would go down.
The second question--
I will give all the three
questions all together, then
you can reply all.
The second question is, we
develop an application that
make possible to the user
to make a music job.
They can--
Richard probably know better
this application that I'm
talking about.
They can compose music, they can
mix, they can blah, blah,
blah, et cetera, et cetera.
We would like to use the In-App
store to make possible
for the users to resell
to us their jobs.
I mean, for example, I make you
the music mix, I make the
very good music song, then
I probably share on the--
of course, on the server
maintained by us.
But I would like the In-App
to resell this product.
And last question is, how do
we do for the API without
Merchant Key?
I know that Merchant Key exists
only for USA and UK
people, but here in Italy, we
cannot use the API, because we
don't have the Merchant Key.
We have just the co-merchant
key.
That's all.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
So I can talk about
the second one.
What was the first one?
I kind of missed it.
I was--
MATT GAUNT: Can he have
reply to comments?
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, fair enough.
Ellie spoke about reply to
comments on our Hangout that
we did with the publisher
site team [INAUDIBLE]
on Monday--
the Google Play Developer
Console preview team--
and she didn't announce
anything new about it.
Just said that we're currently
still trialing it, and we'll
announce something when we have
something to announce,
unfortunately.
On these--
NICK BUTCHER: We hear
you, though.
RICH HYNDMAN: We hear you.
NICK BUTCHER: We want to.
RICH HYNDMAN: The second
question is a reasonable one
to discuss.
So they have an application
where the users of the
application create
sounds and music.
MATT GAUNT: Mm-hmm.
RICH HYNDMAN: And then, in the
app, they want to have a store
where other people can
buy the sounds and
music that you've created.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: And they want that
store to be powered by
our In-App purchases.
MATT GAUNT: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: And then--
so they'll get the money and
then they'll distribute it
back across to the people that
have created the music.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: So the only way I
thought of doing that was to
have un-managed purchases at
various prices, because you
can't really go and start
changing your In-App purchases
for every single track
that somebody lists.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: But then it's
quite hard to figure out what
everybody's bought.
You'd have to manage
that on your--
NICK BUTCHER: The catch was
the-- you can't distribute a
store in our store.
RICH HYNDMAN: But
it's using our--
the In-App billing items.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's not a--
NICK BUTCHER: Maybe
you can use,
like an internal currency.
That would be quite a nice
way of doing it.
SPARKY RHODE: Hmm.
RICH HYNDMAN: And then you
can clear it in and out.
You can buy credits for songs.
MATT GAUNT: And then plus you'd
start then being able to
manage your own transaction
history.
SPARKY RHODE: Wow.
I like that.
Make it like a jukebox and
you buy virtual quarters.
Or nickels, if you're
old school.
[LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, that could work,
couldn't it?
And then you could either
use your currency--
when you upload tracks, you
either get currency which you
can re-spend in the app, or you
can check it out at some
point via--
that becomes a problem
as well.
I guess.
If you're buying, how
do you get the money
back out of the system?
MATT GAUNT: Well, would it
be a problem, though?
Because if you've got the money
that someone's paying to
the developer through the
In-App purchasing, then
essentially it's a separate
agreement between the
developer and then the person
who's made the mix.
So then that's outside
of Google--
GIUSEPPE: I have an
idea to suggest.
I don't know if that
applicable.
We must have an In-App item that
allows to the user to buy
any kind of a list, any item
in the list, in some list,
that have this value
in, like, points.
Let's suppose like coins, OK?
He buy, for example,
five Euro of items.
And each songs, one cost one
Euro, one cost of cents of
Euro, et cetera, et cetera.
And then he can spend these
credits buying these items.
But at the end, the money must
go to the developers, and
divide with the Google,
of course, as is now.
But we must find some way to
give credit to the users, and
then they can spend this money
on any kind of items.
And the items will not
have a price, but
will have coins value.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
GIUSEPPE: Five coins, ten coins,
like games that we sell
around the world.
WIEBE ELSINGA: So you're not
selling the application or the
email purchase, but you're
selling the coins?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
AL SUTTON: Can the--
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, the application
has been paid by
real money.
But the internal items--
so, songs, et cetera,
et cetera--
can be buy with coins.
But to get coins, you need to
pre-pay something, some part.
MALE VOICE: Yeah.
AL SUTTON: Will the songs be
playable outside of your
application?
GIUSEPPE: Sorry, I
didn't get you.
AL SUTTON: When the user buys
a song and downloads it, are
you intending them to be able
to play it outside of your
application on, say,
other devices?
GIUSEPPE: No, I don't.
Not at all.
The song or the pieces will
be useful only for own
application.
AL SUTTON: Cool.
It's just, well, that's one of
the things that's prohibited
by Play Store is downloading
songs for redistribution.
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
SPARKY RHODE: I think
the virtual currency
idea is a good idea.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, virtual
currency.
Yes.
This is what we must do.
SPARKY RHODE: The question is
how much of that can the
Google Play infrastructure
provide for you.
And I'm thinking probably
not very much.
Basically, just the management
and selling of the virtual
coins is about the--
as far as I know, that's
probably about what you can
get from Google Play.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
You're probably going
to do it as an
un-managed purchase, right?
So you're going to have to
have your own server-side
infrastructure to keep
track of each user's
balance, and so forth.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Right.
SPARKY RHODE: As well as the
redistribution of money out to
the artists.
MATT GAUNT: Yep.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, we're
not going to do
anything other than that.
GIUSEPPE: That is the point.
The distribution of the money.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
I don't think we provide
anything off the shelf for
that, do we?
NICK BUTCHER: Well, no.
If Google Music is launched in
your territory, you could
encourage them to do the--
what's that thing where you can
sign up to sell your own
songs on Google Music?
Encourage them to do that.
MATT GAUNT: Awesome.
RICH HYNDMAN: We've talked about
this app for the last 10
minutes, but you haven't said
what your app's actually
called, Giuseppe?
What's the application called
that you're talking about, so
people can go and try
it out if they want?
Oh, you're on mute.
Someone has muted you.
GIUSEPPE: Ah.
Yeah, someone.
In a few seconds someone is
muting me, I don't know why.
Anyway, the name of the
application is Voice Pro.
NICK BUTCHER: Voice Pro.
RICH HYNDMAN: Voice Pro.
GIUSEPPE: Voice Pro.
Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: Lots of native
audio processing.
Apply effects to your tracks,
do lots of different
processing on them, and very
fast in the background.
NICK BUTCHER: But is the rest
of the world ready?
[LAUGHTER]
GIUSEPPE: And what about
the Merchant Key?
NICK BUTCHER: I don't
understand--
RICH HYNDMAN: What about
the Merchant Key?
So you're saying that--
is this the server-to-server
In-App billing?
GIUSEPPE: Mm-hmm.
RICH HYNDMAN: You're saying
that, to use that API, the--
GIUSEPPE: Yes, yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: You need
the Merchant Key?
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
We can't, because we don't
have the Merchant Key.
RICH HYNDMAN: I thought it was
a standard OAuth to log in,
and you didn't need the
Merchant Key for it.
Have you-- you've tried to
go through the flow?
GIUSEPPE: Yeah.
If I check in my Checkout
account, and go in the
settings, I don't have the
Merchant Key like other people
in UK or in USA.
So without the Merchant Key, I
cannot use at all the API.
MATT GAUNT: You do have
to do something there.
You have to set up the account
you want the payments to go to
or something, don't you?
RICH HYNDMAN: I'll have a
quick look into that.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Once we answer
the next question off the
comment thread or
the Moderator.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, but if you will
access from UK account,
you will see the Merchant Key.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
I know that only
UK and US have merchants.
So I'll see what you're
supposed to do.
NICK BUTCHER: See if something
is needed.
RICH HYNDMAN: So just carry
on through the--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
To go to the next question.
SPARKY RHODE: All right.
Should we see what's next
on the Moderator?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Accept one from the Moderator.
SPARKY RHODE: OK.
This is from--
it looks like Desgraci
in Colombia.
It says, "A custom fragment out
of emanation--" Heh, heh,
can't talk--
"custom fragment animation
problem when I pop out a
fragment from the back stack.
The enter animation works,
but the exit one
doesn't, because it never--
it doesn't show the animation,
then it doesn't take the
fragment out from
the back stack."
Don't know.
I'm guessing that if the exit
animation is not being shown,
maybe it's just that the
fragment isn't being removed
from the fragment collection,
like via a Fragment
Transaction.
And I think the back stack
is just a separate issue.
But I'm sort of speculating
there.
I don't know.
Does that ring any bells
with you guys?
MATT GAUNT: Can't say I can
comment on this one.
NICK BUTCHER: No.
The only gotchas I've come
across with those is when you
are adding it to--
when you have the fragment and
you specify your own custom
animations, it just accepts an
ID, doesn't it, which is the
animation type.
And I've had people have
problems when they're
specifying the old type
animations, not the new type
animations.
So, rather than the
android.view.animation type
animation, you need to use an
android.animation type animation.
So I've come across issues with
that way, if you supplied
the wrong type of animation.
Because it's just
an int, right?
It's not type saved.
It's just an int pointing
towards a res ID.
If you're supplying the wrong
kind of animation resource,
then it obviously won't play.
But yeah, I've had
issues with that.
But beyond that, without having
a look at the code, I'm
a bit stumped.
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
So you don't--
OK.
So nothing really jumps out at
you with regards to how to get
the animation and then the
back stack removal
specifically when you're getting
rid of the fragment.
NICK BUTCHER: No, you should
just happen, right?
Like if you just do add to back
stack, null, and then
when you hit Back or whatever,
it should remove it probably
from the back stack and also
play the animation.
But, yeah.
It sounds like that's not
happening, so without seeing
the code, it's kind
of hard to debug.
SPARKY RHODE: OK.
So maybe a good piece of advice
for him would be put it
on Stack Overflow and
send us a link.
NICK BUTCHER: Mm, yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Absolutely.
Have you got an answer
for us, Rich?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
again, using--
I've been through the
subscription documentation.
I can't find anything in the
documentation which suggests
you need a Merchant
ID to use the
subscriptions server interface.
So you get all the IDs you need
from the API console.
So if you can point me to
where you're finding the
problem, I can look
into it more.
But from what I can see, you
don't need the Merchant ID to
do the subscriptions requests.
And I've done an implementation
of it myself,
and made the requests myself.
And I can't remember
ever using that
Merchant ID for anything.
GIUSEPPE: Mm.
Are we talking about
the same API IP?
Because I'm talking about
Checkout API, and not the
Google Play store.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, not the
subscriptions API.
RICH HYNDMAN: Right.
No, Checkout API is
only available in
the UK and the US.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah.
I need the Checkout.
I need to have checks to
the Checkout data.
RICH HYNDMAN: Right.
GIUSEPPE: Probably I say the
Play Store, I'm wrong.
RICH HYNDMAN: No, I'm not
sure that is possible.
MATT GAUNT: And Richard's
off again.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Now I remember something
about that.
The--
yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, let's
move on while you--
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, go ahead.
GIUSEPPE: What happens
if an Italian
developers open an UK account?
What happened in that case?
NICK BUTCHER: What, especially
if you're
trying to sell stuff?
Then your account could get into
bad standing, because you
might have to verify that you
really are a UK business, and
you won't be able to do that.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, at some
point it will ask for
verification.
GIUSEPPE: Not a problem.
No problem.
NICK BUTCHER: If you're
a registered company--
RICH HYNDMAN: If you register
a company in the UK?
GIUSEPPE: I have already,
I have already.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh.
GIUSEPPE: I can use that,
I can use that.
But the problem is to move the
application from the old point
to the new one.
What will happen then?
NICK BUTCHER: That's
simple enough.
GIUSEPPE: Can I change the
account and leaving
the name and the--
NICK BUTCHER: Yep.
GIUSEPPE: Com dot
Voice Pro dot--
like the same?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
You can move an application
between developer accounts,
that's not a problem.
The only complications there
are that-- oh, you'll
obviously have a
new public key.
Because it will be a different
developer account.
So anything which is using the
public key will have to have
the code updated.
So In-App purchases--
GIUSEPPE: Oh, yes, yes, yes.
All the things that use a public
key, I have to update,
reboot, and republish again.
But I can republish under
new name, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
You'd normally publish an update
before the move which
accepts both public keys,
and then move the app.
And then, at some point down
the line, remove the old
public key from your code.
GIUSEPPE: Before to publish to
the new account, I need to
delete the old application?
Because otherwise I will
duplicate the name?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
NICK BUTCHER: No, it's a move.
It's not a take-down and
republish, it's a move.
It's a--
don't do that.
Don't take it down and publish
the same thing, because you
can't, because the package
name will be taken.
GIUSEPPE: Uh-huh.
NICK BUTCHER: There's a form on
the Google Play help docs--
Rich, you want to place a link
to the transfer app form in
the comments?
GIUSEPPE: In the app docs?
In the app docs, I
will find move?
NICK BUTCHER: There's a process
you can ask us to move
an application between
developer accounts.
GIUSEPPE: Oh.
A process.
Oh, it's not automatically.
I cannot do myself, but I have
to ask someone to make--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
don't do that.
Don't un-publish from one
account and try and re-publish
from the other, because you
will not be able to.
GIUSEPPE: OK.
So do you suggest me to open
before the UK account, then
keep in touch with the back
office, and ask them to move
from here to here,
and that's all?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
GIUSEPPE: OK.
But if they will move, they
will move it using the old
code with the old public
key, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
This is why I say, before you
request the move, publish an
update to the application, so
that the application can
handle both the old and
the new public keys,
then ask for the move.
GIUSEPPE: Ah, OK.
AL SUTTON: I just put the
instructions in the chat window--
NICK BUTCHER: Ah, cool.
AL SUTTON: The instructions on
Google Play about getting it
transferred across.
NICK BUTCHER: Thanks, Al.
Do you see that, Giuseppe?
So this is the--
GIUSEPPE: Thanks, all.
Thanks.
Yes, all.
I see, I see.
Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: All right, let's
give someone else a chance to
ask something.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK BUTCHER: Any more Live
questions before we go back to
the comments on Moderator?
ERNEST: Yeah, I actually
have one.
I'm trying to write a method now
that will basically tell
if there's been an update
in the application.
So basically if the version
code has changed.
And I'm just trying to
test this method.
So when I run it in Eclipse, if
I just run the application
with the changed version code,
do you know if that's
comparable to going
in the marketplace
and pressing Update?
SPARKY RHODE: I don't
think so.
I think that's out of band.
I mean, that's the Google Play
application that's managing
that for you.
ERNEST: Mm.
SPARKY RHODE: So that's the
Google Play app on your device
talking to market and
saying, oh, look.
This APK changed.
Let's offer an update.
ERNEST: Well, no, I have in my
application, like, on Create.
Like I have, hey, if
this version code
changed, run this.
But I'm trying to test
that, of course,
before I publish it.
So when I go into Eclipse and
I install it the first time,
on version code one, and then I
change something, and I put
version code two, will--
does--
basically, through Eclipse,
pick up that update?
MATT GAUNT: So--
what--
ERNEST: Does it transfer over
as an update, and not just a
clean install?
MATT GAUNT: It depends on what
you're trying to compare it
to, I would have thought.
Because you can get the version
number for the app
that's installed, but you need
to have saved the previous
version somewhere, right?
SPARKY RHODE: I think what
he's asking is, would the
update process happen
if you changed the
version number in Eclipse?
And I'm thinking, no.
That when you click Run, it's
just going to take your
modified APK with the new
version number, plop it right
on top of the old one--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPARKY RHODE: And run.
But that said, if you have--
I mean, say you have, for
example, databases.
You can have version numbers
associated with your databases.
And your new app can
say, oh, look.
That database is out of date.
Let me run the UPDATE logic for
the database, or just say
have a shared preference
with the license--
ERNEST: Yeah, I have it saved in
the shared preference, so I
guess that's what I need.
NICK BUTCHER: I think
it will work.
Because I think it just ADB
installed on a server.
I mean, you can see it come
out in the logs, right?
When you hit--
ERNEST: Yeah, well, so shared
preferences are persisted
across updates.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
ERNEST: Of course.
So, all right.
SPARKY RHODE: That's just
File, essentially.
ERNEST: Gotcha.
Excellent.
All right.
MATT GAUNT: Cool.
RICH HYNDMAN: Cool.
NICK BUTCHER: Any more
Live questions?
Spartan, maybe?
RICH HYNDMAN: Sorry?
NICK BUTCHER: Looks like
a Spartan helmet.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, yeah.
What is that?
SPARKY RHODE: No.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Looks like--
SPARKY RHODE: All right,
shall I look at
one from the Moderator?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, go for it.
SPARKY RHODE: We've got, "I'm
trying to port some animation
from HTML5 to Android.
What functions in Android, like
skew/rotate images, can
help me out?"
That's a pretty broad
question.
I would say it depends
on exactly what
animation you're doing.
I mean, HTML5 has canvas
animation,
Android has canvas animation.
HTML has WebGL, Android's
got OpenGL.
So basically look at your--
essentially, your animation
package that you're working
in, and use the equivalent
one in Android.
The other thing I see--
NICK BUTCHER: Is that the WebGL
spec is pretty close to
the OpenGL ES 2.0 spec
as far as I know.
I'm not an expert on this, but
I think I've just heard that
anecdotally.
So yeah, I think you just need
to just Google for WebGL
versus OpenGL ES 2.0.
SPARKY RHODE: I also suggested
that the writer actually try
his HTML in Chrome on Android
and see how far he gets.
Some of it might
actually work.
I think the WebGL probably
wouldn't, but the canvas
animation might.
Don't know.
And also, there's the little
caveat that the full version
of Chrome on Android is going to
be a much more powerful and
feature-full than
the web view.
So, what you get it in a browser
app might not be the
same as what you get by
embedding HTML into a native
Android app.
NICK BUTCHER: Indeed so.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
Open-ended question with
lots of answers.
NICK BUTCHER: We're running
out of time.
So lets go real quick.
Speed answer mode.
So Gabriel asks, he is launching
his app, and he has
plans to later introduce
synchronization, which will
require extra permissions,
such as get accounts, use
credentials, incidents
and so on.
Should he launch his app with
these new permissions that he
isn't using yet?
Or should he wait and then
increase the permissions when
he updates?
RICH HYNDMAN: Good question.
I would personally vote for
waiting and increasing the
permissions, even though it
means that people will have to
volunteer to the update.
I think it's worse-- much
worse-- having an application
out there which asks
for permissions
that it doesn't use.
It confuses people.
They wonder what's going
on in the background.
And if you explain it by saying,
I will need these in
the future, it's a little
bit creepy.
MATT GAUNT: And plus, people--
it depends whether they
actually read the
description and stuff.
They're more likely to pay
attention to the list of
permissions than read
the description.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I would go with the minimum list
of permissions that you
can get away with at
any one stage.
MATT GAUNT: And plus, once
you've built up that trust
with the users, when it comes
to updating with additional
permissions, they kind of assume
that there's going to
be additional features
for them.
So--
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
That's true.
NICK BUTCHER: Next!
Speed round.
OK.
Gregory asks, in the Action
Bar Icon Pack there's an
allicons.ai.
How do you extract
certain icons?
I guess the answer is you
use Adobe Illustrator.
RICH HYNDMAN: Use Illustrator,
yeah.
AL SUTTON: Or, alternatively,
the separate icons should be
in the AOSP repository
as individual PNGs.
SPARKY RHODE: You can
also get them--
I mean-- at least from
the developer.androi
d.com/design/downloads has some
downloads that have all
the icons just as separate
models--
NICK BUTCHER: That's what
he's talking about.
SPARKY RHODE: --you can use.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
SPARKY RHODE: But I mean, there
are separate pings in
drawable directories, right?
So you don't have to actually
separate them out.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, but he
actually wants the vectors,
not the bitmaps.
He says, Kenny has it in STG.
So I think right now, unless you
find someone very kindly
to pull all that, I don't
think you can
get there, see that.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Find an app that can read
Adobe Illustrator files.
NICK BUTCHER: Specian asks for
a future comment on when an
NDK support's coming.
So we can't comment on
future release dates.
MATT GAUNT: Yep.
NICK BUTCHER: "I've been toying
around with the idea of
developing a game using
overlays on
a Google Maps MapView.
I've got a working prototype.
But how does the licensing work
for such an application?
Can I even use Maps
for that purpose?"
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
SPARKY RHODE: Talk
to your Geo guys.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you're using
MapView or Maps on the mobile,
it's using the client
quotas, isn't it,
not the server quotas.
So you should be fine.
MATT GAUNT: Mm-hmm.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's on a per
session per client basis.
MATT GAUNT: Good.
RICH HYNDMAN: Is that it?
NICK BUTCHER: Ah, no.
MATT GAUNT: There's
a couple more.
SPARKY RHODE: Andre is
clarifying what he meant by
question three.
He says, "If the account that
bought the subscription is
removed from the phone--
you see, when a subscription
is bought, we store the
information on our database.
And then on every start, we call
our server to check if
the subscription
is still valid.
Now that the account is removed,
that user should no
longer be able to access
the functionality." OK.
MATT GAUNT: I'm a bit confused
as to why they're no longer
eligible to access it.
Because they're still paying
the subscription.
They should still have it.
SPARKY RHODE: I think it's
because the account that
licensed the content is no
longer present on the device
when the device is trying
to talk to the server.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, OK.
So the account has been removed
but the app hasn't
been removed.
So therefore you're
still doing it.
SPARKY RHODE: I would
say, yeah.
If the user account that paid
for the subscription has been
removed from the phone, then,
absolutely, that phone should
no longer be able
to get the data.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: But I don't
know if there's a tech--
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know.
I take it another way.
Because basically you've tied
that user's account to your
notion of their account
on the server.
If they're still logged
in with that same
account with your--
you know, because the source of
truth for the subscriptions
is your server, right?
Basically, your server, does
it talk to our server to
verify it before it renews?
Right?
But if it's still logged in
with the same-- like, your
account for your service, then
I think that's valid.
RICH HYNDMAN: At the same time,
if the device checks
through the Market whether you
are still subscribed, it will
come back and say, no.
If you do restore transactions
or whatever.
NICK BUTCHER: I still think the
source of truth should be
your server, and your server
is doing a service--
telecommunication.
RICH HYNDMAN: Same
with a paid app.
If you buy a paid app and it's
using LBL, then you'd take
their account off the device
and lose access to the app.
And so, it would be nicer if you
did what Nick was saying,
but acceptable in either way.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Are we out of
time, or are we going to do
any more Moderators?
AL SUTTON: There's a quick
one there for Matt.
Any update on the
Google TV NDK?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, so we can't
really comment on that.
There's a massive long thread
which I think Cristy or
Cristian Uccello has
responded to.
So I've literally just
followed that.
Because I think we are following
that thread.
NICK BUTCHER: Thread where?
MATT GAUNT: It is on Google
Issues somewhere.
I can't remember what--
RICH HYNDMAN: There's so
many Google Issues.
There's only so much reading--
MATT GAUNT: I will find it
and then send it back.
Yeah, I'll find it and put
it in the comments.
Any quickies in the sidebar
we can cover?
RICH HYNDMAN: "I'm new
to Android dev.
I would like to ask if I can use
my own database to store
the data for my app." Yes.
Go into
developer.android.com/training
and look at how to store data.
There's a thing on--
SPARKY RHODE: Training.
Basics, Saving Data.
RICH HYNDMAN: Written
by our very own
Munich-based Sparky Rhode.
I shall write that in the chat
bar for you as my last thing.
So you'll have to copy
it out before you--
SPARKY RHODE: So just going back
to an earlier question, I
wanted to comment
about the SVGs.
You were talking about
Adobe Illustrator.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
SPARKY RHODE: If you want a poor
man's method of working
with SVGs, the last time I did
anything with that, I used the
Chrome Web browser to preview
it and I edited
the sucker in gedit.
In just a raw text file.
MATT GAUNT: Wow.
RICH HYNDMAN: Ha ha.
Hardcore.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, yeah.
Awesome.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh my god.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, then.
That brings us to the end of
this week's "Android Developer
Office Hours."
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, also we
have one more on that.
You could also petition
Alex Faaborg who
creates those resources.
Say, please resubmit SVG.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
And hopefully we'll see some
of you who are watching
tomorrow and the day after
at Droidcon London.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Very excited
about that.
MATT GAUNT: Hells, yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Um--
bye?
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: Can we
just leave now?
What a bad day.
And we're done.
AL SUTTON: Thanks, guys.
Bye.
RICH HYNDMAN: Thanks,
everyone.
MATT GAUNT: Cheers.
NICK BUTCHER: Thanks,
everyone.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Have fun.
JOHAN PELGRIM: Bye bye.